twitter is removing thousands of
accounts linked to a conspiracy theory
group that has been spreading
disinformation and harassing people
online
the social media company is targeting a
counseling to
q anon or q followers often seen at
trump rallies believe in conspiracy
theories about global child sex
trafficking
and so-called deep state efforts to take
down the president
and they are aggressive they recently
organized to harass
actress and motto chrissy teigen online
the group linked her without any
evidence
to convicted sex offender jeffrey
epstein they even began
flooding accounts of her friends and
their businesses
yesterday twitter says it had enough
banning 7 000 accounts and releasing the
statement we've been clear
that we will take strong enforcement
action on behavior that has the
potential
to lead to offline harm and tony chrissy
teigen tweeted this
you don't have a right to coordinate
attacks and make death threats it is not
an opinion
to call people pedophiles who rape and
eat children yeah it was interesting the
the twitter spokes a person who was
communicating with the press didn't want
their name in the press for fear of a
backlash but the issue with a conspiracy
theory is when you try to remove the
content
it's a self-ser sealing theory meaning
that it just reinforces the idea
that it must all be true so i don't
think this is the end of queuing on not
by
a long shot black